yes we're now live bob
right uh well that seems my clock tells
me it is four o'clock
so may i welcome all on sunday to this
meeting of the community and resources
committee um
we'll move right on to the
agenda item one apologies for absence
i have no apologies chair
right item two
public contributions we have
four contributions which have been
written and submitted in the proper
manner
which will be read out by the um by
steve hurst
thank you um so the first one you'll see
is from
peter and linda lindley so it starts i
am writing in response to the discussion
about the possibility of providing some
free car parking in torridge car parks
i hope it will be possible to read out
my contribution at the meeting
august the 17th in december
on the occasion of a grinch christmas
event
organized in torrington free parking was
provided
i just popped into torrington to change
my library books and pick up a few
things at the shops as i do most
saturdays
what a joy it was to see the town so
full of people and the shop so busy
i realized this was because of the
grinch event but the fact that the
parking was free was surely another
factor
when a day's parking in baseball can be
had for 1.70
the cost of parking in torrenton seems
steep i am sure
is a factor in fewer and fewer people
shopping there
many people come into torrenton from
outlying villages to visit little
and then go straight home so they don't
have to pay to park
so impulse purchases at local shops are
prevented
and people buy all their groceries up
littles
if parking were free or refundable i
feel sure
they would be more inclined to get some
of their shopping at torrenton's
butchers bakery
hardware store etc at this time in
particular when local shops need all the
support they can get
providing free parking would be a real
real boost
to them i feel the role of the council
is not merely to generate a funding
stream via parking charges
but to nurture and support the local
business community
since just in penrith is a small town
between penzance and lands end
very much a work day sort of place and
in many ways like torrington
in particular it has that sense of
community that people so
value the council clearly recognizes
that providing free parking is an
investment for the town
and as as a result the town is thriving
something needs to be done to prevent
torrington dying on its feet
and free or refundable parking seems
such an obvious and simple way forward
kind regards linda limbley
uh the second one from great torrents
and town council
um so great torrance and town council
members understand that the above
committee meeting
uh district council members will
consider
councillor mcgoss mostly as set out
great tonington town council members at
great torrance and
council's council meeting on the 25th of
june
2020 voted to support the original
motion
and continue support the revised motion
in particular the town council supports
a two hour free
period of free parking and in both car
parks
please note that in great harrington a
lot of traders remain working
to cover 19 induced open times are
currently
opening at 10 am therefore we'd request
that any free parking is not restricted
to specific hours
prior to 10 a.m if possible great
torrington hosts a number of small
independent shops and businesses
many of whom have been closed for a
number of months and have limited or no
reserves
whilst the national grand scheme would
have assisted these businesses when most
of them were closed
we're now very conscious as they start
to reopen
they will remain pressures for a number
of reasons
high footfall is key to the success of
these local businesses
and anything that will encourage people
to visit the local shops and
communities is welcome over the past few
months people have got out of the habit
of venturing outdoors
and we see now with the lifting of
restrictions people remain
nervous of stepping outside we know from
feedback over the years that parking
charges
are a drawback for people using cars to
visit the tram center
at a time when we need to help get
businesses up and running it's critical
that we endeavor to help
remove any obstacles we can we currently
have the added issue that people are
nervous about having to walk too far
and or catch a bus into the town center
in fact government guidance encourages
encourages the use of either a cycle or
car
rather than public transport any period
of free parking
would help facilitate use of a car which
again will help footfall in the town
center we have worked with torres
district council and the chamber of
trade
over these past few months in
preparation for reopening of
non-essential businesses
and the hospitality sector and we have
been grateful for their input
the provision of any free parking for a
period of time would be hugely welcomed
and positive extension of this work
therefore in the interest of promoting
increased footfall and spend in our town
centre
thus helping the myriad of small
businesses to get up and running
following an enforced shutdown the town
council fully supports the motion to
allow
a period of free parking in sydney house
and bali grove car parks for as long as
possible
we would like this representation to be
presented to members considering the
motion
please acknowledge proceed to this
notice and that's your sincerely
counsellor keely allen mayor of great
torrington
uh the third one is from evil inmation
and it starts dear sir madam i feel that
the free parking being discussed for
torrington
is absolutely essential at this time due
to the pandemic
businesses have been hit hard and
together with increasing unemployment
it is going to make it difficult for
small independent businesses to survive
these in torrington are essential to the
town and we must do all we can to ensure
that traders have
every support they can be given nothing
will be more devastating than to see
businesses close and more shops become
vacant
this has a knock-on effect as footfall
in a town will decrease
because visitors will no longer wish to
visit somewhere which does not have a
vibrant
environment that they will feel happy to
stay and browse in
walking around the town which has lots
of empty shops will mean they will not
stay
and won't return free parking will also
make them feel that they're welcome to
the town i should be grateful if you
read my comments out the meeting to
discuss
free parking girls faithfully eve nation
uh the fourth and final one is from
brunelli ralph
um stars please read out at the meeting
inside 11a of torrington
support the proposal for limited free
parking for the towns in the torridge
district
given the recent announcement of the
deepest recession that this country has
seen it's in its recent history
due to the covid19 pandemic it is
absolutely paramount that local
businesses get as much support as
possible
free limited parking has been has been
proven to boost football in top grade
torrington
and i'd expect the results to be similar
in biddeford and holdsworthy as well
in torrington we offered a refund on
parking for one hour to shoppers
while the pavement was being relayed
this was financed by the chamber of
trade at
absolutely no cost to the torridge
council it made a difference of that we
have no doubt
the footfall in the town declined
rapidly until the chamber of trade
intervened most shops had literally no
turnover for three months and since
reopening
we are slowly making in roads to help
mitigate those losses
anything that the council can do to help
will be greatly appreciated
be it in the run-up to christmas or at
any other time
free limited parking will benefit the
top traders of the towns
your sincerely bryn and jane roth inside
11a torrington
which is all for public speakers
thank you item 3 declarations of
interest
i just need to warn you that if you have
an interest
you must declare it item four agreement
is the agenda between parts one and
two to my knowledge there are no there's
no suggestion of a part two item
so we can move on item 5 urgent
matters i have none
so we move to the main bar to the
evening notice of motion
free car parking page is three to seven
on your agenda
i don't know but i guess sean is going
to take this one is he
that's right
oh steve right sean you're muted
is that better can you hear me now yeah
sorry chair
yep so the report in front of you sets
out and presents the
uh notice of motion as proposed by
councillor mcgoff that was referred to
you from full council on 27th of july
the introduction section of the report
gives you a bit of background
there was a big debate at your last
meeting as you will all recall so i
don't propose to
go through the pros and cons of free
parking because i think that was done
at the last meeting the main body of the
report
sets out a table so that you can see the
costs associated with a range of
different
options uh of free parking for two hours
so the first table looks at the cost of
free parking in each of our car parks
until
nine or until 10 and the figures
associated with that are in the table
and the bottom table of the two
sets at the cost of one hour free
parking for two months
or two hours free parking for two months
but
no specific time so these are any times
of the day and they're averaged out
across the year so they're not in any
specific month so
for instance january would be cheaper
august would be most expensive
if members were minded to provide
any form of free parking support we
would request that you consider not
making any concessions to
permits or reserved bay um
these and charges because obviously
there's quite a lot of work associated
with
uh amending those we would had we would
need
to change our software for our pay and
display machines but this can be done
but one thing you would need to be aware
of is that people would still be
required to um put a tip get a ticket
put a ticket and display in the car
when they came to the car park even if
it were in the free period
because that's the only way we'd be able
to find out when they arrived in the car
park and when we should start our
enforcement
and we also wouldn't propose to make any
changes to any events
or license arrangements we have on the
car parks because otherwise you know
again that would be us revisiting all
those those documents
quite a lot of work associated with that
you'll see that there's a
supportive comment from councillor
hodgson as the lead member for resources
and then a summary section of the report
which sort of sets out much of the
background information
um again the management section it sort
of talks a little bit about our
request for how these things might be
managed so
i'd ask members if they'd like to
consider the report and the
recommendations they're in
uh happy to answer any questions thank
you sean
right i'm gonna put it to uh councillor
mcgoff on the basis it's his
uh proposal councilman mcgolf
thank you very much mr chairman uh thank
you very much for the report there sean
um the first one i'd like to start off
with is there was definitely nothing in
my motion that even
related to the concessions of the permit
or reserve bays
of the duration and emotish from the
motion at all
obviously we weren't aware they get
concessionary rate anyway that's why
they
applied for the the um the permits
um a couple of points i would like to
touch on to the
parking display machines um i'm glad you
clarified that we got the software to
actually upload these that the new
uh the new obviously if we do invent two
hours free of parking
um i'd like to move on to make a
proposal i want to propose
that we uh present the two hours free
parking
this would then give the public and the
business owners
enough time during the cover 19
obviously we got restrictions in place
in shop centers and any shop you go into
where you've got sign into books or you
have to stand in line to queue
to cleanse your hands and two hours to
me i feel would be
the most appropriate at this time i need
to touch on obviously the 72 thousand
pound
now this is this is my view in view a
lot of other people
this 72 000 pound you're not losing this
as a council
you're investing it back into your local
businesses
and residents and it's going to come
back tenfold in a local economy
this is how we're going to be proactive
as a council we generate
good income revenues other places we
should subsidize what we need here
but for this to come back tenfold is key
empowerment to these local town centres
that need to actually survive in this
time
um it's been mentioned on the previous
meeting that free car parking
wouldn't make any difference to shopping
at all wherever mr nick
giddy who owns a bit of a carpets he had
a property on the peel car park in
biddeford
since he'd relocated um down by clarence
wharf on the
near the outskirts of biddeford he's
introduced free car parking because his
own land and his business is turned over
30
extra visitors coming in because of the
free car parking
i've done my due diligence here as many
business owners
and residents as well we've done moment
reports together and this is the
feedback that came
so obviously i'd like to propose that we
go for two hours free car parking
with no limits on it as in
i don't want to see it between just
eight or ten because
people got different routines in their
life and different times they can access
the tank centers
we can't limit it to eight or ten that
to me is
going a reverse of what i need to do i'm
trying to get footfall back in the tax
centers
encourage people back in spending money
again to limit the two hours free
parking
to that time would it be beneficial in
my view to the residents of torres
and specifically torrenton holsworthy
and principal biddeford so i move for
the two hours free parking
any time of the day that you come in as
we're all aware we have to punch in the
registrations
into the machine which will give you
proof of who's actually access to car
parks
i am aware it's going to be a bit more
work for the enforcement teams at
torridge
they do a great a grand job anyway so
they're more
capable of handling this so
obviously i look for a seconder please
i would like to second that if possible
i'll use your first speaker
or counselor bright was the first one of
his hand up
right counselor bright put his hand up
and seconded the motions i understood it
yester
chair you've also got council hutching
with his hand raised right councillor
hutchins
off you go um i was going to second the
motion actually
um but just to um sort of
ask a question really um i noticed that
it looks to me like every car park in
biddeford is mentioned
um i know when we first started we
started talking about uh
main car parks i just wonder how many of
those car parks
um i mean there's a lot there's a a long
stay car park well
as far as long stay means i presume that
doesn't really require two hours free
parking
um but i just want to clarify which of
those and maybe from
other counters in biddeford which of
those are important
and are they all needed because some of
those car parks obviously there's a lot
of money
um involved so if you could take some of
those out
but i agree i've done it for the two
hours
uh one of the officers comment please
sure i can i can comment if you like um
i mean obviously you've got your your
main car parks in biddeford
being the most uh important car park
busiest car park i would suggest is
probably
riverbank now anybody who's familiar
with riverbank car park
uh will know that the short and long
stay uh sections of the car park
are aren't all that clear there's some
signage i mean people
would have to read when they go to the
tariff boards
but it might be a bit
problematic if you were to offer
in half of the car park one arrangement
and in another half of the car park
another arrangement clarence wharf is
probably
as you can see the least popular
shoppers car park
that's more a commuter car park that
people come in park there
go to town bridge street the key
the pill they're definitely shoppers car
parks
um they're very town central and uh they
are for the people who pop in and out of
town go to the shops
so i guess it's for members to decide
whether they want one
or all or none um but that's just an
oversight overview of the car boxer
thank you sean oh chair the other
the other thing if i might be permitted
i should have said whilst i was
presenting
um should members resolve to
support some free parking obviously
you've got your five days
for the decision to become valid after
this meeting
um it'll then take us a number of days
to
to get the software changes and make the
necessary arrangements get the right
signage out in place
we'd probably be looking at the early
september as a start
if if that were acceptable thank you
right i've got five wishing to speak
i don't know who's top of the list it's
council of right chair
first right councillor bright
thank you chair yeah i i had to second
um
councillor mcgoff's proposal because oh
as
you saw in the report as well in the
public contributions that most of the
people well this time all of them were
from torrington and last time most of
them were from torrington
so i feel i wouldn't have been doing
them a just duty
unless i supported the two hours free
parking at any time
and it will definitely benefit the
businesses we've it's been proven before
and so i had to support it
thank you uh councillor lock next one
with honda
yeah i was going to bring at the same
point as councillor um hutchins
i could support two hours street park at
any time
but with nominated car parks only i mean
in torrington i would nominate sydney
house car park
um and billy bird i would suggest just
the key
because that is the one that's nearest
to the shops the most relevant for
shopping
and obviously holsworth has only got the
one so that will bring down the total
cost of 29
000 pounds which i think it's a lot more
palatable if you just have one car apart
from each
town um
it's the question whether you're going
to vote we heart or your head really
because i mean there's still a lot of
income to lose
in these difficult times but i also did
another exercise and asked for
information about how much
um council travel allowances we paid out
from march to august this year
and we've only paid out 2148 travelers
allowances for councillors
compared to 6593
last year so in that point you are
saving 4415.
so i could support to ours free car
parking
if we limited it to those three car
parks thank you
all right councillor bushby
thank you chair um yes i think we should
just um
leave it as it's presented on the on the
report
out of all the car parks i think if you
try and uh pick and choose you'll just
muddy the waters and confuse everyone
and you'll get
people whinging about well why why isn't
this car park that's where i always bark
um so i would leave leave it as it's
listed
um i just wanted to pick up on one of
the points that sean mentioned about
licensed events um and clearly in a
normal year we would get probably quite
a few
license events but i don't think for
this period
certainly not this summer anyway um i
don't think there's any license events
that are applicable to this application
am i right sean
uh chair if it's okay um then we have
one or two small scale events the large
large events are obviously prohibited
because of the social distance in
guidance at the moment no nothing over
30 people
currently but there are one or two
events
um that are going on uh in in our car
parks that
are fairly small scale okay thank you
chair
right council of laws next
nick you're muted chair i am a
shopkeeper but not in one of the
uh the towns mentioned so i feel that i
can
speak vote and perhaps offer
a thought or two
we're in such difficult times and nobody
seems to be
really dwelt at all on the cost
now i am very supportive of um
helping the shopkeepers
um people are flexible you know
and if they know it's free up until 10
in the morning
they will come then and the effect
on our budget is far less if we do it to
10 in the morning
and we simplify it even further by
saying
one parking ground in each town for
example you could pick the
pill in biddeford it's level with the
shop set with with the center
uh it's got good capacity um
but i just feel that
i'm sure the people that voted for us
realize how difficult it is
and i don't expect they truly understand
yet the financial position we're in
we can't really truly honorably
give away money that we haven't really
got to give away
we could be we could be having to feed
people shortly we don't know what the
future holds
but i think in support of
councillor mcgoff uh i'm
happy to support two hours
up till ten one parking ground in each
town
is a really nice gesture which i feel
will help the shopkeepers
show torridge in the right light but we
can't just go give away thirty thousand
pounds like
we don't have chancellors please
chairman thank you
thank you uh councillor wiseman next
thank you chair um unfortunately i
missed the previous discussion because i
had an emergency to deal with so perhaps
i'm
behind the curve here i don't know but i
think there's still
um a great lack of evidence to be
perfectly honest
how many of these um of this 72 000
pounds for
for two hours free parking for two
months how many of those
are workers cars how many of them are
shoppers cars
uh it's easy to blame shop uh the cost
park and nobody likes to pay for parking
i ain't
paying for parking but when you go to
town you go to town not because it's
free you go to town because they got the
services or the products
that you want to engage with i've been
going to biddeford
quite often lately since this was first
since this was first proposed and i was
in there on saturday
saturday afternoon i was surprised at
how busy the town the town was
and um so i can't people aren't going
to town because online shopping is
becoming so popular sixty percent now
of all retail shopping is online
previously to the covid have been
growing ten percent every year
i do feel as if the for offering free
parking is kind of swimming against the
tide a little bit
um there's a fire is suggesting
one car park or two car parks in
biddeford and one in the other towns
uh what i think that would provide is
par a great
cues that those nominated car parks
people will sit there
sit there waiting for a car parking
space
to become empty rather than if they're
gonna park all day they'd like their two
hours free thank you very much
and uh instead of distributing amongst
all the car parks which could prove
provide great congestion um
72 000 pounds it's a heck of a lot of
money to have to give up
it really is and we are not in a great
position
and the government probably isn't going
to bail us out and back us up
this is it's got to be a very very very
good case that we will encourage
extra commerce and i can't see that it's
been made
thank you uh councillor mcgarth wants to
come back
famous chairman um just to reiterate
again
um you know investing back in our sound
centers is the local economy
which is absolutely dead on its feet it
needs to be revived
i'm trying to give it a chance to revive
it this is important
to torridge um what i need to stress
obviously
we did we were our own worst enemies
when we passed the proposal atlantic
village
we killed the heart of our town nobody
can go against that because i'm
dead 100 true on that fact and it
provides
free parking which encourages people to
come in to the shopping centers
i have nothing against atlantic village
my wife works there
she's got a good job there and the
football people there is due to the free
parking
right next to it is asda let me guess
asta's got a free car park
for a certain amount of time it's a free
car park you can't spark it all day
but guess what you go and interact
you're spending money
and the money is then returned to local
shopkeepers and workers cars let's just
remember one thing
when somebody comes into a town center
to visit a center they're spending money
in the town center everybody whinges but
i've only got an hour on a ticket i've
got to get back make excuses during this
covered now
you can't come into town and nip in the
town for an hour isn't it it's not even
impossible
if you follow all the social distancing
and the rules and regulations that we
will have to abide by now
you just can't do it obviously i'm
trying my best here to get this through
um if you actually work in town yourself
what do you do at lunch times
hopefully you go in and you support your
local economy by eating some food
what's happening in that moment people
are coming out of the town centers
they're going to the car parks they get
a bit longer for lunch
and then they're eating away at the time
i'm trying to get people back into the
town centers all these town centres are
struggling and they really need it
to start breaking down you know the
money seventy two thousand
a lot of money yes seventy two thousand
is a lot of money and to be honest if we
already
work from own bank accounts a lot of you
wouldn't spend
the ridiculous amount of money you spend
on the council and like the losses we
made for kibble was 1.7 million and we
never even got to it
we would have been actually a bit savvy
but it got would just sit there and talk
to them first they had to spend on that
huge checkout which is publix money
let's get one to find straight people
pay money for cancer attacks what do
they get for it
not a lot in return at that moment
unfortunately that's not putting anyone
down on the council's i don't need no
officers jumping up and down
i've totally respect what you do for the
council officers and the refugee people
and
absolutely fantastic people they were
the key workers through the covered for
me
let's get this council tax what do we
get what services did you actually
provide for the public
it's being cut and cut and cut
you're saying about trying to get
revenue coming from car parking i need
to touch on
page five sustainability implications
the ins and incentivization of a car car
use through free parking
would appear to be at odds with the
council's climate emergency declaration
what a contradiction of terms that is
we're at
odds with it and yet so the best thing
for us to do is to get free car parking
absolutely totally all over the car
parks forever
because if we don't and we're relying on
this as a revenue income
you've shot yourself in the fur what are
you doing you're coaching these houses
housing as well at moment every house we
pass through planning
on average has two cars it counts the
locker notice i don't agree with counter
locks comments about not being worth it
because it is
um if we just say two thousand dollars
come in a bit of the next
next ten years well that's an average
four thousand cars coming in
i'm responsible for that as well if i
sit in the plans committee council
christie is
kind of so wise beings on it okay so
locks on it we all sit there
and we do have a challenge a moral issue
on there between ourselves with it
because you're passing this and you are
going against a climate emergency
how far we got requirement emergency how
much money we're going to pump into
climate emergency
is going to be on beyond belief we don't
know
you can only solve it with money and
unfortunately money gets things done
thank you chet thank you councillor
brenton next
you're muted david
i'll start again okay sorry about that
um
i say the first point i'd like to make
is that it has to be
two hours at any time otherwise it does
penalize rural
uh people who come into biddeford i mean
we really don't want them
racing along the roads to make a
deadline by uh
by 10 o'clock you know that is just not
practical at all
and even during the height of the crisis
there were
quite a few people in bitter who came
from outside
of the town itself in order to do those
key things like
the chemist and banking in particular so
we we have to be mindful of that so it
has to be two hours the other thing on
the notice of motion it doesn't say
which two months and i propose that the
two months
really ought to start in uh
october and then november because
at the moment we do have a lot of
visitors around and i don't think
there's any problem with
um filling up the car parks or indeed
the shops are very busy or frankly you
know
as long as it seemed busy benefits so
busy councillor wiseman was quite right
you know on saturday it was busy
there are so many visitors around it
seems a little bit silly to be
uh giving free parking at that
particular time they'd be bunged up in
no time and it wouldn't be with
local people i suspect so it shouldn't
start till then and then that would tie
in as well
end of november with um with what
that certainly biddeford town council
does namely that uh
they have a arrangement with torridge to
subsidize some free parking
during the month of december end of
november so uh
to encourage people back into the town
so that would tie in nicely
it would help then to have a continuity
of
ethos of some free parking
uh that would certainly alter the
numbers i think really
so i i do think that uh as i say the two
hours is definitely important because as
members have already pointed out social
distances mean if you
for example go to boots on a busy day
you could be waiting outside a long
time if you want some medication so
that that's my proposal those months and
that uh
it should be a flexible two hours
thank you cutler hutchings
thank you chair we mentioned license
early on i don't think
i have an interest although i will
mention i do have a license for the car
park at the moment in torridge
um but i am um hiring it a space for a
whole day
so this doesn't actually have any impact
on that right so i will declare an
interest
um i have a um uh something from
councillor jones he asked me if i could
read it would be okay to read
yes it is i've already said so okay
thank you
um so now this is from councillor jojo
karma here um i apologize i'm unable to
attend today but i have written this
submission
um i hope this submission will suffice
as i've made clear from the start i'm in
favor of one hour's free carping in
carpark in our towns
but i especially think hosley will
benefit from this in order to help our
local business belts back
i'd like to take issue with a few parts
of the report firstly
paying car owners and non-car owners off
against each other is an absolute
nonsense
we all know when our town centers thrive
will benefit regardless of the modes of
transport
interestingly we don't see this point on
any reports to do with spending money or
time on the promotion of cycling
where which would not benefit many of
the elderly residents of our district
this is a complete non-point this
follows nicely on the idea
that if it wouldn't be fair for our
coastal towns which is complete red
herring also
our coastal resorts as they are called
in the report benefit from the tourism
in a way
somewhere like holsley plainly doesn't
it's ludicrous to suggest that other
towns shouldn't benefit from free
parking
because it doesn't include these resorts
clearly different areas have different
needs
western ho recently had and rightly so
investment and repair and a slip weight
however the benefit of this won't be
felt by people in holistically
who go to the beach imbued this doesn't
mean that building a slickway wasn't the
right thing to do
it just simply that different areas have
different requirements and we shouldn't
fall into the trap of having to treat
everywhere in the same way
turning to the idea that this will
benefit people who don't live in the
district are a tourist by the time
this could come into place the summer
season would have largely gone
but as i said if it encourages them into
town centers then our local economy
benefits so it's simply
for the benefits of tourists i firmly
disagree with council hodlin's idea of
two hours free until 10 o'clock
this would not give people the
flexibility they need also this would
contribute to the issue
of residents parking
sorry i'll turn that down um
however when i was free parking was
going to the problem disappears
regarding the issue of enforcement as
number
plates have to be entered into the
machine
um do the machines not have the facility
to stop people from claiming multiple
free one-hour parking tickets in the
same car park
that is only just that is to say only
allow them
one free ticket per car park per a day
everything i've said relies on the
premise that paying for parking
regardless of how little for an hour
deters people from our towns
i think this is the case certainly
wholesomely this is seen on a wednesday
where the square is shut due to the
market which removes
the free parking shopkeepers have been
informing us that the quieter
that it's a much quieter day although
pre-covered the veil of whitehorse
district council trialed
free car parking for two hours and they
concluded that without
without it there would be 10 reduction
spending in the market towns in question
so there is evidence to suggest that
this is a positive effect
in terms of the financial costs we're
working with estimates
as councillor james sorry
as councillor james send previous cnr
meeting
on this matter as less people are coming
into some of our towns the actual
financial impact may be smaller
than we are anticipating i also wonder
why there was no information report
about
how the cost could be met the notice
does ask for an explanation into how the
shortfall in the budget could be covered
one suggestion was rebalancing of the
higher parking tariff
if such information was provided emotion
may be more appealing
other areas have taken it from the
bottom end and placed it on the top
finally i support the motion and
disagree with most of the report but i
would suggest that members consider each
town on a case-by-case basis
they are not the same at our very
different needs nevertheless i think
they would all benefit
from this motion and i thank councillor
mcgough for pursuing persisting
and putting this forward the only thing
i would add to that is the fact i do
think our towns are all very different
um and i think that we um poseworthy for
instance
who doesn't have any tourists um we
would actually benefit on the first of
september not the first of october
unlike biddeford thank you
right thank you
um councillor leather next
is not a member of the committee for the
public benefit
no i'm not thank you chair thank you for
allowing me to speak
well i've looked through the report and
for many years i've pressed
for some free parking in our areas but i
do think that
we ought to be offering from 8 to 10 in
the morning
i know the point that was made about
people who live out in the sticks out in
the rural areas
but you can get into holesworthy well
within an hour
from from that area you can get into
torrington well with an hour
into biddeford people do traveling from
rural areas into the towns uh so i don't
i don't think that that's an issue
really a lot of people get up very early
to go shopping
a lot of people in biddeford go out
early shopping but i do think
72 000 is too much money for
i don't think we can afford that
presently i've wanted
for a long time to move the parking back
from eight in the morning till ten
o'clock in the morning
and i think the banks are all and then
the shops are open then if people want
to come in and take
advantage of free parking that's the
time to come and do it
i i and and also
i noticed from the list mana car park's
not on there unless it's been
lumped in with the key but mana car
parking biddeford is not shown on there
which is one in front of the hsbc bank
um and that's a very busy car part
one but yeah i would support and i know
i'm not on the committee so i'm not
voting but i would support the
i think councillor hudson mentioned
putting the bar
free park until 10 o'clock from 8 to 10.
it used to be
not that many years ago we charged from
nine in the morning
till four o'clock in the afternoon then
it was moved to eight and it was moved
to six o'clock
so i think the the start of the day is
the best
people say well people who park on there
overnight i'll stay there till 10
o'clock
i don't believe that's the case because
most of those people go off to work in
the morning
and shift the cars off the car park at
eight o'clock they've got to get to work
in the morning
but it's a case of suck it and see let's
see what the benefit is
from doing this for a two month period
you could extend it for another two
months after that
and still be well with below this 72 000
to give carte blanche but i wouldn't
pick
a specific car park i would do the ones
that are listed there chair
thank you
thank you uh sean
thank you chair i just wanted to come
back on a couple of points that uh
councillor jones had raised
um so first the machines can't stop
someone from getting another ticket
that's not possible we check that out
with the software providers so that
can't be done
um and uh what was the the other point
no it's gone from me now chair so it
kind of been that important so i'll
leave it there i think the manner was an
omission from the report though picking
up on councillor leather's response
it's not included in the key
right councillor coddle hankin
not a member of the committee
hello and thank you for letting me speak
um i just wanted to reiterate that i
would support
two hours at any time and in both car
parks in great torrington
i've heard quite a few people have said
maybe we should just pick one car park
from each town
but the smaller car park in torrington
leads straight down through the pannier
market
so i wouldn't like them to lose out if
only the bigger car park was chosen as
the
selected car park also many of the shops
don't open
until 10 o'clock so i wouldn't recommend
these before 10 o'clock sorry um
as suitable especially for torrington
anyway um
if cost is a worry then maybe it makes
sense to pick
two car parks in biddeford rather than
all of them
um that would be my suggestion thank you
for letting me speak
thank you councillor wiseman thank you
chair that's an interesting point there
that mr kearney has just raised
i'm how are we going to police this if
people can just go and return
to the ticket machine and go every two
hours and get another one and another
one and another one
could we just have some clarification on
that
said chair yes um that's what we'd need
the enforcement officers to do
so their handheld devices would be able
to um record who's been in a car park
they'd also need to display a ticket so
they're going
go up to the machine they select in all
likelihood what would we describe as a
zero pounds tariff which would give you
a ticket for two
free hours um display that that
obviously qualifies
and then the next time if they come into
the car park and that machine
um that car is still in the car park
sorry their handheld devices would let
them know that that car
car's been there before and they
shouldn't have another zero hours
ticket or zero pounds tickets sorry
thank you sean chancellor christie
thank you chairman um well it's been a
fascinating uh
discussion so far all sorts of odd
things have cropped up
um but can i just ask a couple of
questions
uh council of laws raise the serious
financial situation torridge finds
itself in at the moment
can i ask what is the shortfall between
what
torrid is spent on coved measures
and uh any funds we've received from
central government
give people some idea of just how much
we have spent in this current
situation and secondly um do we have any
breakdown of the uh the current take up
of one hour and two hour tickets
because quite a few years ago my
students actually did a survey of
biddeford
park car parks and we did find that most
of the take-up of tickets was
for one hour now i do take on board
councilman mcgoff's point about
queuing in shops although i must admit i
haven't really noticed it in biddeford
the only place you really cue
and biddeford is the banks all the rest
seem
to work very well but there's two
questions there
um i take on board council the col
hankins point about the shops don't
really open uh four or nine
so having free parking eight that's
pointless
um i would actually like to second
counselor brenton's proposal
that we bring this in in october and
november
because it will tie in with the need for
uh
extra trade leading up to christmas at
the moment the town biddeford i can
speak
for biddeford i've been down there today
i go down there every day
it's absolutely heaving at the moment um
i think council brenton's got the right
idea for that but if i could have
my answer my answer for those two
questions thank you
okay david how you should answer the
first one
okay david
a little bit of a difficult question to
give an answer for because there's still
a lot of things that aren't uncertain
um we've received the best part of one
million pounds just over 1.1 million
pounds from central government at the
moment towards the impacts of covid
um our expenditure to date is relatively
relatively insignificant compared to
that figure in terms of
um agency backfill for the refuge people
for people isolating
xrit equipment um
ppe deep cleaning etc and some grants
that we've made to the communities and
the parish town and parish councils
however
the biggest losses everybody here is
fully aware of is our on our income side
in terms of our lost car parking income
and other sources of income
and the government has announced that
they will pay us 75 pence in the pound
for any lost
income and full details of this scheme
have yet to be released so at the moment
the financial position of the council
is looking compared to many councils
actually quite healthy in
in some respects however there are
caveats to that
um if there was to be a further lockdown
obviously
our car parking income would just drop
off a cliff overnight
um we don't know the full extent of how
many people claim local council tax
support
once the furlough scheme ends and the
furlough scheme is now starting to
unwind
from august employers have to pay the ni
and pension
of employees on furlough and from
september they only
recompense for 75 and i think it goes to
i think
percent from october so by october the
furlough scheme we ended
and there was we potentially see a
significant increase in claims for local
council tax support
um so there's that and obviously we've
also discussed leisure
um you know our leisure centers are not
open at the moment we've had those
proposals from 1610 and
officers still working through that but
that's a potential
expenditure and the scale of that will
depend on the options that members
eventually
choose so going back to councillor
christie's original question the
position at the moment
is good but there's some serious caveats
and the situation could change quite
quickly
thank you uh steve i've got you
top of the list steve house chief
executive yeah
church i think uh sean needs to answer
the second part of council christie's
question first
about the number of our hourly tickets
chad thank you um yeah i don't have that
information to hand but the last time we
looked at this was an association with a
request for two
hours free parking and what i could tell
you was at that point and i can't see
any reason why it would have changed
was that about two-thirds of our total
parking income is gained within the two
first two hours of parking so you know
if
in a year um we were taking just over a
million pounds
around 700 000 pounds of that is taken
in the first two hours of people's
parking tickets
there you are right councillor bright
thank you chair i'd like to clarify a
couple of points
i just want to check my figures to make
sure i'm right and saying
that uh were we 36 000 pounds above our
predicted budget on car parking last
year and i'm also wondering because
we've got two
separate proposals but they aren't
actually at odds with each other can
they
are they both voted on or is it just
that we vote one
or the other for clarification
we will take them one after the other
they'll both be voted on
but if one is agreed the other one will
die
councillor pennington
thank you share just a couple of clarity
please um david talked about 75 p in the
pound from government for lost car
parking revenue
i'm just listening debate in the urban
areas i know uh transport from london
had to carry out a lot of work just to
get the subsidies from
central government are we affecting any
opportunities to get that 75 p in the
pound
if we choose to lose income from car
parks so just
grateful for clarity on that question
thank you chair
who's going to answer that one i'll
respond if that's okay
yep yeah um central government told us
that we've got to do everything we can
to maximize our income so they wouldn't
recompense us for
lost parking income that would be as a
result of a decision that we
made ourselves thank you
councillor mcgoff
famous chairman um just a point of if
this motion passes today
the motion i put forward i got seconded
when would it go back to full council
and when would it be the time scale that
gets implemented
first question please another one after
that please
you can have another one after have the
answer
okay i actually answer that um it
depends one of the things that
councillor jones picked up
uh was that there's been no uh
indication in the report about how this
will be funded
now obviously the notice of motion
stipulates that the cost to be
met uh decided by members considering
but not limited to reviewing the capital
program
and or rebalancing current car park
tariffs
so within the table on the on the report
on page five arguably it could be a cost
of
anywhere between seven and a half
thousand if the cheapest of each of the
car
one car park in each towns was done for
free car parking until 10 a.m or up to
73
000 if there are it's just point of
orders mr hursley
i'm asking you for time scale uh when it
can be implemented from
to go back to full council not for not
football additional costumes
we will get that answer i think if you
let the whole explanation
come out chair that's what i'm saying so
it depends it
if it was at the cheaper cheaper end
then i think we can probably
uh within the council's budget manage
that cost so for example we have money
coming back that was given to the parish
and town councils
for the community response we estimate
in that
currently available around 47 000
so if members then wish to put 36 000
back to their councillor grant
that would leave somewhere in the region
of 11 000
pounds so at the cheaper end of these
options that could be funded and that
could be a decision taken at
this committee and subject to its not
being
called in by scrutiny then as sean
mentioned
earlier by the time that
period passes and the parking machines
are upgraded it could be done from the
first of september
now if it was at the other end of the
scale 73 000
and we've got to seek where that funding
comes from
then that may need another decision at
full council
there you are council mcguff you've got
it next one
did say that was the first part thank
you very much for chairman
obviously uh mr harris is aware of my
motion i've put forward what's the 72
thousand 682
so i appreciate it but yeah a long way
around a short route wouldn't it
no i'm trying to touch this with council
brenton because if it's going to be
in the middle of september before we get
anything through for a full council
then it's likely that it is going to be
in october so i'm happy to add that as
an amendment council
councillor brenton to my motion
i don't see the point in two separate
motions i'm happy to do that if this is
time to see how it's going to be it
would just hurt from assassins now
that would then coincide in what you're
saying so i think that to me that makes
common sense
i'll second that
that's capture the bushby seconding it
it was
thank you right councillor james wanting
to speak
all right thank you chair i've listened
um this morning
i was on a zoom call which included mid
devon
and as you know mid devon introduced two
hours of free parking and when it was
discussed this morning
the leader of mid devon said his advice
to us was don't do it
it's more hassle than it's worth now
having given that
i still i'm not convinced it will
increase
the footpr footfall appreciably um but i
am prepared to say
that if we can do things to help
shopkeepers that's fine
i'm slightly disturbed with some of the
comments from shopkeepers that they saw
their footfall go up when we we didn't
actually suspend
car parking charges we stopped enforcing
it when the actual fact the shops were
in lockdown anyway
and we didn't reintroduce charging until
the 15th
which is when non-essential shops opened
so some of the comments from shopkeepers
are slightly misleading
again having said that i still think
we need to find a way possibly to help
the shops that we can afford
and at the moment we seem to be going
round and round with different proposals
um i would have been quite happy to
support
councillor hodgson's proposal it seems
we've moved on to that
it looks like biddeford are going to
make a massive uh
saving whereas probably the place that
needs the money
most is holdsworthy and to a lesser
extent
um so i'm becoming more and more
confused
and i think we need to have some clarity
exactly on what
if we come to a vote are we going to
simply vote on what's on the agenda
or are we going to start adding
additions to it um i was
a bit worried about what sean sean said
about
the car parking but that's assuming that
our car parking
attendants are going to go go around
checking the two hours all the time
but i'm open to some some suggestion
thank you chair thank you councillor
james councillor lock
yeah we're following on from what steve
has just told us um
my original idea was just to pick one
car apart from each
town which would cost a total of 29 000
pounds which steve has said we could
implement
and bring into falls on the first of
september whereas if you
stuck to all the car parts it cost you
72 000 pounds
so i'm still in favor of two hours free
parking
but for a selected car park only in each
town
because we can afford that straight away
and then that would help shopkeepers
straight away from september
thank you councillor leather
thank you for letting me come back
briefly um
i think it would stalk some confusion if
we picked
one car park and i think as councillor
wiseman said
some time ago you'd have people queuing
up to get into that car park
but what what just concerned me
listening to the debate further
if if these two hours are voted on any
time in the day
then you're gonna have people come
hardly anybody will be paying parking
in any of the car parts because i think
most of the visits into town
certainly and as sean carney has said
most tickets in for an hour nobody's
going to be paying any parking
it strikes me that we're going to lose a
heck of a lot of money if people can
come
any time of the day and park for free
for two hours i just think it's
ridiculous that
nobody will be paying i i think
everybody will be coming in
having two hours free and going home
again i i just can't see
that we can certainly afford to do that
it's ludicrous to me
councilor hutchings committee member
um council jones mentioned it in his bit
um
do we have to take all three areas in
the same vote
or can we vote differently for each town
because holsely is different to
torrington which is different to
biddeford
and um as sorry i think it was um
council lot just said
you know causeworthy is is a minimal i
mean if you said an hour's free party
house you know we're talking less than
three grand
um compared to sort of 22 000 in
biddeford
so do we have to take all three together
or can we make decisions on the
different towns
i would have thought we can make
decisions on the different towns life
will get very complicated but
i believe yeah i believe the the notice
of motion seems to allow that because it
says some or
all car arcs and it names the term so
it doesn't have to doesn't indicate it
has to be the same in each of the terms
there you are right council advisement
thank you chair i've got the button in
the end right as councillor james just
said just now
um it is getting confusing everybody
seems to have a pet theory on this one
and that many proposals being bounced
around and the reason for that i think
is quite simple
because there is still no clear evidence
that free parking will increase the
amount of football or commerce
in our towns as i said earlier people
don't go shopping in a town because it's
free to park
if they're going to go to the town
they're going to spend 20 30 40 500
pounds whatever it is
a pound for parking doesn't put them off
they go and spend a pound on parking and
five
pound on a cup of coffee and a bun when
they get there
the re people go shopping in the town
because the towns
provides them with the services and the
products that they require
that's what that's what we should be
concentrating on
not trying to undercut ourselves all the
time
like on mid-devon also mid-devon said
don't bother
i wonder why that is because was it
because the paperwork was too difficult
their machines were too difficult
or because it made no difference that
would have been a bit more interesting
if they could have enlightened us a bit
further to be honest
i on my mind is coalescing now i was
waiting to be convinced that free
parking would be of benefit
to our town and our and our residents
set
up to 72 000 pounds worth of good for
them possibly
but i it's not been proved and i don't
believe anybody can prove
that it will be of any benefit even
though we all
hate paying for parking we all do it
when we need to go to town so let's
provide
an answer to people's needs
gentler laws
people need to feel supported
and we can do that but i'm still of mine
that we can only go
halfway now i've listened to cheryl and
i've listened
about holdsworthy and yes they are the
places that
really do need support now i'm going to
make a proposal
if i may uh that
we give free parking till 10 in the
morning
in all three towns two parking grounds
in ho
sorry do you have two parking grounds in
holes for the awamba
all parking grounds in holesworthy all
parking grounds in
torrington and one parking ground
in biddeford
and definitely definitely chair my
experience
in westwood hill tells me do not start
this until october october
and november um and if needs be we can
go on beyond that
because else they will just get choked
up with visitors
and that's that's my proposal and i know
it's probably not the most
popular but be showing support and we
can afford it
hopefully thank you chad
thank you councillor bright
thank you chair yeah i'd just like to
point out something uh councillor
wiseman
said is that people would go to the
towns
relevant of the like because they're
going for the service
but on the doorstep the thing i'm
hearing is people will go to asda
morrison's waitrose because it's got a
free car park right on the doorstep that
is why they go there
everything's there in one place and
without supporting our local independent
traders
by using free parking you know
we aren't really helping them
princess james
thank you chair i've come back on a
couple of things one is mcdevin just
said to me this morning
it was never worth the hassle it um the
influence was it hadn't made any
difference
there had been a lot of falling out
amongst the um
uh the council about it but i'm not here
to comment on what they said other than
my advice received this morning was
don't do it
um kind of surprise um yes most people
go to supermarkets
but and yes it's free parking but you
pay somewhere
um but also we we need to encourage
people into the tones for what it is
uh and this is only a short stop measure
if we did do something what it won't do
is prolong the life of the tones
um or in any way you say the door stop
arguments are you here um and as i said
earlier
the the arguments i've heard from some
of the shopkeepers didn't add up
i'm quite happy to uh support council
laws
resolution but i just feel we're now
wandering into
all sorts of different um arguments
yeah we've got no proof it will improve
but if we can do it without going
completely mad
i'm quite happy to try something um and
i think
what i i do notice that
in the mornings a lot of locals pop into
the shops for papers or for the atm
and stuff like that and they they don't
want to pay for the car park so they
tend to park on the road outside the
shops
which cause a problem so i think that
would be a sensible
affordable uh solution i think
on the others which and again i'm not
sure
with biddeford i'm not happy with every
car park in biddeford being free for two
hours
because if we do that in any part of the
day we're virtually wiping out most of
our car park income
so i think we just need to find a
solution that is affordable
and is sensible and is workable and so
on that basis our
support council laws
thank you chad no i just wanted to come
back on um councillor law's
uh proposal there because um actually
well parking holes with the and the
cattle market in biddeford although
that isn't listed on here we can't do
two hours free car parking in those
because they're a pound all day it's the
only tariff in those car parks
so they're one pound all-day car parks
we can't change that without changing
the parking order
counsellor lock
well i was going to second council
laws's um
proposal then but then that's got to be
changed then to
just holdsworthy manor car park both
car parks in torrington and just one in
biddyford for two hours free parking
eight to ten if cancer laws agrees with
that
i totally agree with that chair
right councillor bushby
thank you chair uh i'm i'm really
dismayed
um it's staggering really that you know
this is why you know historically very
little
ever happens in in our towns
you know that's good that puts a
positive spin on anything
you know we've talked we've talked and
talked and talked around all around the
houses
on what is a very good uh proposition
put forward with the best of intentions
and yet you you go all around the houses
you end up talking yourself
out of it you water it down to the point
where i'm almost feeling oh what the
bloody hell are we doing here we may
i don't know why derma even bothers to
bring something like this forward
you know there's just so much negativity
yes of course free parking is going to
help
our local um shopkeepers our local
business
there's no there's no doubt in my mind
that that's a fact
i've been on the chamber of commerce for
years i've been on the town center
partnership for years
and the same message gets said over and
over again
town center parking is is putting people
off coming into the town
um you know we've talked about all the
out-of-town shopping centers that have
the benefit of large car parks
yes they've got a massive advantage all
we're trying to do here
is just narrow the gap a little bit for
a certain
period of time i totally agree with the
the
october november yes you want to do that
when the visitors have gone home
and i'm sure that currently councilman
mcgulff would
would uh you know be in agreement with
that but in his put forward a good news
emotion here
he's done some great work you know
we're talking about you know a mere
pittance here in the big scheme of
things
you know you've had a proposal it's been
seconded
you know i've had enough of the talk
let's get to the book
i've had lots of proposals cancer
hutchings
um i just want to say that i'm from
hozi's point of view because obviously
that's what i'm most concerned about
um free parking till 10 o'clock would
actually cost more than it would for one
hour's free parking
so if i had a choice i'd rather take one
hour's free parking
than i would till 10 o'clock um have
expected a lot of shopkeepers in the
last few days
um most of them don't even know until
after nine o'clock so until 10 o'clock
doesn't really help anybody but one
hour's free parking which is actually
cheaper
which is why i go back to do we have to
discuss all three towns as a warner or
we did them individually
because i'm presuming torrington would
probably prefer an hour's free parking
rather until 10 o'clock if it was a
choice
and once again that would be cheaper for
them as well
councillor mcgoff
thank you mr chairman um just to clarify
again
obviously my motion as i stated uh with
the amendment with
councillor brenton they're saying
obviously implementing on the first of
october
obviously i've not heard of council
brenton was actually happy with that
that would then take a notice of motion
off the table
obviously include his name in it
obviously he wants his name in it right
quite rightly so
long serving bit of a counsellor
counselor christine hopefully support it
um that i i agree with occasions to
bushwick and this and
thank god we got council of bush beyond
the council
because he talks sense and he gets
straight to the point we keep going
around being negative you're not losing
72
000 you're investing it back into your
local
business owners who pay the rates they
employ local people
they therefore go back and spend money
in the local economy it's going to come
back tenfold
and for the trial period of two months
this was to actually see
and give us a good indication if it
works
you can't just pluck it at the air and
say will it work won't it work
he's been on commerce he's been on time
center partnership they're all in
support of it
now this gives us two months then to say
did it work or didn't work if it doesn't
work
i'll load my hands up and say i'm really
sorry i try my best for my local
community
you can't really go wrong there can you
thank you
right no one with their hands raised
so oh councillor brenton popped up
sorry chair i'm sure you want to move to
the vote because i'm sure all of us want
to move to the vote
i just want to point out really that uh
in terms of the
the two months period october november
is uh councillor mcguff is totally
entitled to put that forward
himself it doesn't mean my um uh input
into that it's his notice of motion
and that's what we're voting on isn't it
i mean i've had all these other
proposals but they're not
they're not phoned up and some of them
are direct negatives to what is actually
there on
on the table in front of us i think you
know
we can afford to experiment with this
we can afford two months of trial
and give it a go i mean if it's a total
failure
and the shopkeepers turn around and say
no this didn't work blah blah blah blah
and never do it again but i think we can
afford
two months it won't be 72 000 because no
in those two months
it'll be a considerably less uptake
so i think there's nothing to lose by
giving it
a try i went to ely years ago a
lovely town georgia buildings massive
cathedral
you you know you go there because you
want to
right bang in the middle i park my
camper van for
free and i gotta stay there all day
but people aren't stupid they move on
etc etc
so you know as i say there's plenty of
evidence to show
it's worth the effort and it's worth the
experimentation
to try it so i'd ask counselors just
support
counselor mcguff's notice emotion you
know you could tell him later
told you so and slap him around if you
like but in the meantime
let's give it a go thank you
right now i have a formal
proposal from councillor oh councillor
christie
uh i'm gonna call it a halt after this
one and
try and move it to a vote councillor
christie
thank you chairman um as the secretary
of council of brent's motion council
brentwood is now going to support
councilman goff for the two hours
i think it's going to begin in october
i'm not sure if i follow that
uh i'll withdraw my second i'll support
councilman goff
i will just say one thing uh which it's
a bit late to say it really but
um years ago when the chamber of
commerce wanted
uh free parking i was the councillor who
actually introduced the
free parking after four and the idea was
that's what the shopkeepers wanted
because they wanted to extend
their time that was their quiet period
they wanted the cars to come in then i'm
not sure putting it on first thing in
the morning as councillor kofo hunkin
said and other councillors have said
uh putting on eight o'clock in the
morning does seem a bit
well pointless really absolutely
right now can someone help me what
proposals do i actually have on the
table now
shall i shall i come in with that so we
have
uh and bear with me members because it
will take a while but
i have noted them all down so we've got
councilmember goff's original notice of
motion as in the committee report
and then councillor mcgough proposed two
hours free parking
with no set hours and that was seconded
by councillor bright
and then councillor brenton proposed for
two hours free car parking in november
and december
that was seconded by councillor christie
although councillor christie has now
withdrawn that so that one's removed
from the table
then councillor mcgoff has proposed a
dinosaur
amendment for october and november and
that was seconded by councillor bushby
so that's two hours free car parking for
october
and november and that's the one
valid one on the table at the moment is
it
well we do have um then that we have the
proposal from councillor laws
for free car parking until 10 a.m in all
three towns holesworthy torrington
and biddeford for october and november
and that was seconded by councillor
james
and then we do have a further proposal
on the table
by councillor locke for two hours free
car parking between the hours of 8 am
and 10 am
and that was seconded by laws council of
laws so i
i suggest chair we take the motions in
the order that they've come in and that
would start with
councillor mcgoff's uh notice of motion
sorry amendment for october and
november in all car parks which was said
seconded by
councillor bushby right
brenton
it was on october november i i proposed
not not uh november december
so it's all it all ties in it's all
right it doesn't contradict
okay counselor laws yes i need to come
back
and just clarify uh what stacy's just
said
and that was uh not free parking in
torridge
per se it was free parking on one
parking ground
[Music]
sorry council laws i've got it one car
park in biddeford but the other three
yeah so holdsworthy torrington and one
car park in biddeford for
october and november thank you
right councillor lock and that that is
the motion that i
second it counts the laws motion that
you just read out
i seconded that one
okay so
can you pray see them what are we voting
for now stacey i want everyone to be
very clear
yeah um
so that we free car parking um in all
car parks for the months of october and
november
just to clarify that is all car parks in
holesworthy torrington and biddeford not
all car parks in torridge
yes
yes two hours for october and
yeah that was november one proposed by
my counselor mcgoff and seconded by
councillor bushby
that's it mr chairman just pointing
clarity for you obviously that there was
no
uh time limitation on it you know not
just eight to ten
and any time like the day as long as you
present your ticket
right but for two hours total counselor
mcguff that's right
any time of the day two hours title yeah
right let's put that one to the vote and
see what happens
recorded vote please thank you chair
councillor brenton
you're muted came to the brenton
councillor brenton
you can hear me i can now thank you
or sorry when all the buttons went mad
thank you cancer brendan councillor
bright
paul councillor bushby
or spencer christie or
councillor hicks four
pencil hutchins or ansel
james or pencil
laws against
councillor locke against
councillor mcgrath
sorry i got so excited there come press
the button four
councillor wiseman against
thank you chair that is one two three
four five six seven that vote is eight
four and three against chair
so that is carried and as i
understand it we don't need any other
votes do we
no we do not no
end off so
it's my pleasure to thank you all for
your attendance today
through the chair excuse mr chair
can i just just ask some clarification
of what happens next please
yes certainly we'll put it over another
three
okay sorry so obviously a decision
notice will be published
probably tomorrow um then obviously that
would be subject to call in if any
members so wished
um so it's five clear days um
then given the value of the
the cost we probably need um that
recommendation to come to full council
with how that's going to be funded
which as it's october november
that's been approved um that can be
added to the next full council
meeting subject to the chairs approval
of the agenda
and the chairs on the meeting today so
i would assume councillor brenton would
add that to the
agenda of the next full council meeting
thank you councillor brenton is that
correct you will
oh go on i will yeah right will you
devil
right okay
answer your question counselor hutchins
you're happy now
much appreciated thank you right
i'm going to declare the meeting closed
thank you for your attendance